growing measles outbreak in the Pacific
Northwest is spreading fear among many
parents Washington State has neglect
declared a public health emergency there
are now 35 cases in Clark County alone
it's part of a worsening measles problem
across the country Jamie yuccas is
outside a Walmart in Vancouver
Washington one of more than 50 places
confirmed as a public exposure location
Jamie good morning good morning it's
places like this Walmart schools
churches and grocery stores where people
may have been exposed measles has an
infection rate of 90% for anyone exposed
and not immunized with no visible
symptoms for weeks this is what the
measles looks like it's not just
uncomfortable it can be deadly
studies show almost 30% of children
younger than 5 who get the measles will
have to be hospitalized parents are
concerned like mother of three Miranda
Smith it's their lives on the line
honestly if they're not vaccinated and
something like this happens then what am
I going to do to save them the 35
confirmed cases in Washington State
prompted governor jay Inslee to declare
a state of emergency this can be a
serious disease and you need to get on
top of these things quickly to prevent
really significant spread 18 states
including Washington allow parents to
decide not to vaccinate their children
due to moral personal or other beliefs
there were nearly 350 measles cases
recorded last year in 26 states and the
District of Columbia the second greatest
number since the disease was eliminated
in the year 2000 New York State is
facing its worst outbreak in decades
with more than 200 cases it's very hard
to change people's minds especially when
are you talking about the health of
their children bulimic Marcus is a nurse
practitioner in New York working to
combat misinformation that claims
vaccines cause cancer diabetes and
autism all disproven by the CDC
she says this anti vaccination pamphlet
has been distributed throughout
Brooklyn's ultra-orthodox Jewish
community where 62 children have
contracted the disease I think that
percentage is higher in the Orthodox
Unity's due to all of the propaganda and
fear tactics there are so many pieces of
misinformation some outright lies that
when put all together reveal a very
terrifying picture of vaccination the
virus is spread through the air and
lingers if one sick child coughs in a
room and leaves another unvaccinated
person can still be exposed
hours later officials now worry the
virus will spread to other large
metropolitan areas what types of things
are you doing to contain it
we're having our children stay home for
a number of days we're asking people
actually to be diagnosed in their homes
not actually to go to the doctor's
office because that can infect people in
the office now if children get the
measles vaccine they're 95 percent
protected Washington State has
introduced legislation to remove the
personal vaccination exemption but it's
already facing some opposition from some
parents who feel the bill takes away
their freedom viana Jamie thank you and
people have such strong feelings about
this it's one thing to protect your own
freedoms it's another to infringe on
other people's health and the science is
very clear on this that vaccines are
safe yeah she bitchin she said
ninety-five percent that's not a hundred
percent that five percent can be a
matter of life and death for some small
children on the question of the measles
but on the question of a link between
vaccinations and autism the CDC in 2013
says there is no link that's that's what
did you say Nora the definition of fake
news right some of well those mean Flitz
that people are handing out is really
disturbing and I'm glad we showed that
yeah